I'm here in Minneapolis three years
after the George Floyd riots devastated
City Block after City Block I make a
point to come back here pretty much
every summer to see how the city has
progressed since 2020. have things
gotten better buildings businesses lives
have they been rebuilt are race
relations any better I'm going to try to
answer all those questions and more for
you over the coming nights but right now
I want to bring you something that we
did not even have planned
we were driving to an interview today
when my Crews and I saw a group of young
girls picking up trash now it was a
hundred degrees in Downtown Minneapolis
today and I hopped out in the car and to
find out what was going on I was blown
away by some of what they told me
they're going around neighborhood parks
picking up trash helping the community
keep clean and the kids making it safe
for them to play at the playground why
are you doing it
because
we feel like
it's important for the kids to play and
be able to be safe at playgrounds while
they're around what are you picking up
that's perhaps unsafe for them
just plastic glass cleaning up the
inside of the park do you feel safe in
the neighborhoods around here walking at
night walking at night no especially not
being a young lady with all the
components going on a lot of city
leaders are saying things are getting
safer in Minneapolis three years after
George Floyd what are you finding I feel
like the crime rate is going up if
actually all the gun plans going on and
all the youth dying the the major
neighborhoods are getting more dangerous
why do you feel like the neighborhoods
are getting more dangerous I'll hear
gunshots like a lot of nights I remember
I heard the gunshots and then the next
morning they posted this kid like um
R.I.P I'm like bro like I just like you
can hear it happening and someone just
died like a little bit not too long ago
a couple days ago I believe just so many
people are dying around here so many
kids my age
what does that make you feel like to
hear these stories this is your
community this is where you live it's
heartbreaking because like many people
kids they die a day and I just don't
think it's okay that like people are
just like just shooting around like it's
a community and then they shouldn't they
shouldn't be shooting like just for fun
or just because some like gangs like
it shouldn't be happening how do you
inspire other young people to avoid the
life of violence and crime that is
attractive because they make a lot of
money doing it
um just get into more activities
enjoying programs to just stay out of
trouble so you won't just be on the
street stealing cars killing just for
fun I advise everybody to just go
and do something what's the difference
between like what's happening now with
violence in the city and what was maybe
the case three years ago three years ago
with gunbones it was more like adults
dying because they were the ones in the
gangs it was like due to all the loss I
feel like the people the kids now
they're doing it I feel like those are
the parents that were lost and they
don't have father figures they don't
have mothers they don't have like nobody
so now they're the ones in the gang and
they're the ones promoting government so
is it a cycle yeah yeah I believe it's a
cycle and the ages just get younger and
younger yeah right because it's like
some of my homies they're like they you
know like five years older than me maybe
um they little brothers and they low
because of like they they go down a hill
and it's like all of y'all is trying to
get into this game business it's like
bro we're we're kids and y'all just
fitting into stereotypes
how young are they in gangs these are 15
14 15 14 7th graders sixth grade it's
like India it vary and then they teach
it today little siblings it's like we'll
see videos on Snapchat like little kids
holding a gun it's like bro what do you
all do yeah they're making it the new
trend basically right yeah they're just
launching a weapon in your camera
um there was a there was literally a
video going around where these two kids
was in the bathroom playing with a gun
she asked them and shot her cousin and
then she shot herself and y'all still
playing with guns and cameras I don't
understand it yeah and Dennis some
people that do have father figures and
mother figures that will just like try
to follow the trend so they're getting
their stuff in like more self-esteem
yeah basically and they think it's fun
but it's actually very dangerous and
when they do get put in a scary position
they wish they would have never have
done it before but it's like it's too
late you're already in you already got
yourself into something
these were wonderful young ladies
volunteering their time to try to make
their neighborhood better it was
inspiring I'll continue to bring more of
my Anglo investigation to Minneapolis
three years later but for now that's it
for us tonight hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else